hey everyone
welcome to this video on the
installation of parrot security
operating system there are multiple ways
to go about with this installation
many people prefer to install it
directly onto a hard disk where the
parrot security os will overwrite
whichever data the hard disk already has
now this is beneficial if you want to
preserve your data for the long term but
this might pose some trouble to people
who do not have a spare hard disk or do
not want to lose their current
installation of windows operating system
another way to use parrot security is by
using the live boot but whatever changes
you make to the live boot operating
system those changes are removed the
moment we restart or shut down the
system
a very good common ground between both
these installations is virtualization
using virtualization software like
vmware or virtualbox we can install
parrot security on our systems while
simultaneously saving our data and
having the convenience of a host machine
such as a windows operating system in
case things go wrong
to start the installation we first need
to get a iso file for the parrot
security operating system
this can be found at the current website
parrotsac.org
once you enter the website move into the
download section
and
select the get security edition over
here
parrot security os has multiple desktop
environments to you to choose from this
desktop environment serves as a
different user interface for the user
for example right now we have the made
desktop and the kde desktop as you can
see from the screenshots both of these
look quite different while having a
similar look and feel to them
for our example let's go with the made
desktop
we have two options either we can go
with the direct download or we can get
the torrent file
for this example if we press on the
download button
and our download will start
i have already downloaded this file but
the iso file provided over here will
serve as an installation it will have
around four and a half gb of space
it will be used to install this
operating system in vmware
once the file is downloaded we can close
this and open vmware workstation
vmware can also be used as a player
version or the workstation version if
you have much more familiarity with
using virtualbox or virtualization
application we can use that as well
once the vmware is open
we click on file and select a new
virtual machine
for the first time installation we're
going to go with the typical and
recommended installation procedure
instead of an advanced one
if you have already installed multiple
virtual machine oss going with the
advanced option will give you much more
control over the hardware customization
but for now we're going to stick with
the typical option
moving on it will ask us for a source to
where to install the operating system
from since we're going to use a live iso
first we're going to select the third
option which will be i will install the
operating system later and press next
as we already know parent security is a
debian derivative so when selecting the
guest operating system type we're going
to go with linux
and the selection we're going to choose
whichever the highest version of debian
is along with a 64-bit os
we're going to click on next
we're going to name our virtual machine
let's say
parrot security
os we're going to select the location
where we want to save
the virtual machine
this will have all the hard disks of the
operating system installation
we're going to click on next
for the disk size we're going to specify
how much of the current memory are we
going to allocate
this is the hard disk memory of the
operating system installation whatever
changes you make in the operating system
whatever applications we install on the
virtual instance will all be stored in
this amount of memory while it is
recommended to go with at least 15 gb of
storage we can go as high as possible
and we're going to select the
recommended 20 gb
as written
when given the choice of storing the
virtual disk as a single or multiple
files many people want to keep their
virtual instance in a way so that it
helps them stay portable
people change systems and sometimes they
want to swap their instances between the
work and their personal computer
if there is no portability in mind
storing the virtual disk as a single
file gives the best performance and
should be the recommended go to when
installing for the first time
we click on next here
and it's going to give us a summary of
the settings we have already settled
till now
we're going to press on finish
and there we go we have our installation
first step completed
here on out we're going to click on edit
virtual machine settings
here we're going to have a look at some
of the requirements that the parrot
security os will need
it is known to be a memory lightweight
operating system but just to have the
almost optimum performance we're going
to provide around 2gb of ram from our
host system which is a windows 10
machine
when it comes to the processors
i'm going to increase it to 2 and the
number of goes to 2 as well so giving
out a total 4 processor cores to the
operating system now this depends on
what are your computer rig and how much
resources you can justify so these need
to be customized according to the system
at hand
hardest size has already been set at 20
gb and the rest of them are pretty
standard and we can go on
one thing that we need to make sure is
selecting the cd dvd ide
here we have to use a iso image file
over here
previously it should be used physical
drive and at auto detect we're going to
use a use iso image file over here
we're going to click on browse
we're going to go to where we have
downloaded the iso file which is over
here
and select it
press ok here
and we can now power on this virtual
machine
at this point of time there are two
options we can go with the try install
option using the graphical user
interface or we can go using the
terminal mode
to get a better user experience we're
going to go with the try install mode
specifically press enter
and it's going to start the live boot
iso
meanwhile
vmware has an
prompt over here but it will try to
install some vmware tools on it while
this is not mandatory it is much more
recommended to install these tools so
that you can get some additional
features like drag and drop with the
host system and many more things for now
we are going to close this prompt
as you can see
this is the live boot iso of the parrot
security operating system
currently it's running the mate desktop
as we have downloaded in the website
the live boot iso is necessary to get a
good feel of the operating system there
are many good linux distros that have
this live boot option so that you can
give a try of the operating system
before installing it permanently
you're into the live board we can start
up with the installation using the
shortcut
as you can see install parrot
i'm going to double click it
and this is a calamaris installer
choose your language as american english
and press next
you can select your time zone according
to your location
and we can go next
at this point of time you have to choose
the correct keyboard now what many
people go get confused is choosing their
own language keyboard what people must
keep in mind is what keyboard the laptop
provides
most of the systems that come pre-built
provide the english us keyboard so
whatever keyboard you choose make sure
to type here and test that all the
buttons including the superscript and
the subscript buttons are working
correctly before moving forward with
this step
once you've settled on the keyboard that
you need to install
you can go ahead
here it will ask you to select storage
device and the only option you are going
to get
is the amount of hard disk storage you
have given
in the virtual machine settings we have
already provided 20 gb of storage we're
going to choose that
and we're going to erase this disk
manual partitioning can be useful when
you're going to install
parrot security on an operating system
or on a hard disk where it is already
including a windows os
for now we are going to select erase
disk and press next
we are going to give our full name let
it be simply learn
you can give the name of the computer
and this is the username which we will
use to log in
this is your root password that we are
going to give over here the root
password of this kali linux will act as
the administrative access and it will be
necessary will make changes to the
system or installing an updating
software
enter the password
and repeat it over here
you have the option to login
automatically without asking for the
password but for security purposes it is
recommended to keep this disabled
click on next
this is another summary of the
installation that we are going to move
forward with
have a look that whatever changes we
have made is according to your
requirements and once everything is
checked you can press on install
click on install now
and we're going to let it complete the
work
as you can see the installation of
parrot security is now completed
we're going to make sure that we have
the restart now button over here
disabled
i am going to click on done
we are going to shut down this live boot
iso
going to click on menu
turn off the device
and shut down
but not restarting straight away because
if you remember correctly in the virtual
machine instance settings we had given
it an iso file
please remove the live medium and press
enter to continue we can just press
enter to continue
and it's going to shut down
now to move on we're going to click on
edit virtual machine settings
we're going to cd dvd and we're going to
use physical drive now
we're going to remove it from the iso
image file because the installation has
already been completed and we don't want
to use the same iso file again and again
by using physical drive over here it's
going to detect the 20gb hard disk that
we have already provided and
installation is done on it
i'm going to press ok
and we're going to power on this virtual
machine for testing
make sure this
you clicky s over here
this is the grub menu
at this we get different choices for
example which nvidia drivers off or with
some other advanced options
more often than not we're going to
choose the first option and press enter
if you remember clearly
we did not get the option of try install
or a terminal run just like we did in
the live boot iso since this is running
straight from the 20gb hard drive
storage it's going to start the os
directly
now with the login screen you can see a
username over here as we provided in the
installation
we're going to enter our root password
and press enter
and this is a currently working desktop
of the parrot security operating system
we can open the terminal over here
and we're going to try a root password
and installation
to install
any software we're going to use the
keyword sudo
apt
install
and neofetch
we're going to use the root password
that we used to log in
going to press y for yes
this is just an additional step that
we're doing to check that the
installation is done correctly with the
correct amount of hardware requirements
that we had provided
now that we have installed neo fetch
we can write the command near fetch
and this is going to give us some
information about our installation
you can see the os name as parrot os
4.11 is running on a vmware host so the
kernel versions and some of the other
information like the number of packages
installed the current shell version
resolution of the vmware instance that
we are running the desktop environment
which is made as we had downloaded once
and some other things you can see the
memory is supposed to be 1951 megabytes
which is supposed to equal around 2gb of
ram usage that we had provided
with this we have completed the
installation of the parrot security
installation hope you all enjoyed if you
have any questions regarding this please
write them in the comments section and
we will get back to you as soon as
possible thank you so much for watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here